blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
pakman we have a ton of legislative news
to dig into today we'll be talking about
the equality act
we will be talking about coveted relief
but before
talking about any of that massive news
late last night the house
of representatives thanks to democrats
mostly
this was this was democrats who voted
for this democrats in the house have
passed
the massive voting rights and
anti-corruption bill
h.r democratic congressman roe khanna
talked to us about this when we
interviewed him last week
and this is not the first time that hr
one
has passed in the house it's the second
time that it has passed
just like the first time it passed it's
not clear how it passes the senate and
we'll talk about that but this is an
extensive bill
800 pages all sorts of of different
things contained within it
but the big items are a national system
for automatic voter registration this is
something
i've been talking about for a decade
it's something that would dramatically
increase participation in elections and
it would ask
right now you have to opt in if you want
to register to vote the default is if
you do nothing you're not registered you
have to opt
in the system proposed in hr1
would create an automatic voter
registration system where you have to
opt out if you don't want to be
registered to vote and why would you do
that if you don't want to vote you just
wouldn't vote
and most people would just remain
registered
the bill would require every state to
put online
options for voter registration
correcting your voter registration
canceling or designating a party
affiliation
things that in other countries are just
obvious that you have any developed
country should have these things
the bill would require at least 15
consecutive days
of early voting for federal elections
and early voting sites would have to be
open for at least 10 hours a day this
would short-circuit and preempt many of
the
state-level voter suppression tactics
that republicans have been using for a
long time
and the bill would also ban states from
restricting someone's ability to vote by
mail
and it will also require states to
pre-pay postage on return envelopes for
mail-in voting so it doesn't cost
people money to vote by mail the bill
would ban
voter roll purges and also would ban the
use of non-forwardable
mail as a way to remove voters
from roles every one of these elements
goes directly at a technique used by the
right to suppress
the vote and very interestingly hr1
establishes a public financing of
campaigns
with small donations the federal
government would do a voluntary
six to one match for candidates for
president and congress which means
every dollar a candidate raises from
small
donors the federal government would
match six times over
and the maximum small donation that
would be matched is capped at two
hundred dollars it's not funded by
taxpayer dollars
the money comes from a four point
seventy five percent fee
on criminal and civil fines fees
penalties and settlements with banks and
corporations
that do corporate malfeasance very
interesting way to structure and finance
this
and it also contains and again we can't
possibly cover
every line but there are transparency
requirements for political advertising
in hr1 it would establish nonpartisan
redistricting commissions to end
partisan gerrymandering massive issue
again we've been talking about it for a
decade it would require
presidential and vice presidential
candidates to disclose uh
10 years of tax returns and
we know directly what that's related to
it would stop members of congress from
using taxpayer money
to settle sexual harassment or
discrimination cases
and so many other things now beautiful
bill
has passed the house how does it pass
the senate
and the answer is it doesn't unless it's
modified
significantly but maybe something can
pass
the question is why democrats control
the senate
democrats voted for this in the house
why can't
democrats pass it the answer is there
are just too many moderates
in the democratic party in the senate
and the majority is too slim
in fact it's the slimmest possible
majority the senate is 50 50 democrats
republicans
because democrats are in the white house
kamala harris becomes the tie-breaking
vote
in the senate when there is a 50-50 tie
but
this requires 60 votes to pass the
senate so in other words
i'm unsure that if it only required
50 it would pass the senate but they
need
60 votes anyway now one idea that
democrats are thinking about
is amending the senate filibuster rules
so that any
democracy reform legislation like hr1
could pass with a simple majority
instead of 60 votes
now that's great if joe manchin goes for
it and that's very much unclear
if gene shaheen goes for it i don't know
if this is a bill
that jeanne shaheen is interested in
passing so
right now the situation anyway is you
need 60 votes now this is an issue
on which there is almost no overlap
between democrats and republicans we
talk on this program you know some some
shows love to take these black white
positions like there's no relevant
difference between democrats and
republicans
and the truth is that on some issues
there's no relevant difference between
democrats and republicans and on other
issues
they couldn't be more different
democrats at least in the house
are passing h.r 1 which is a massive
expansion
in voting rights it would permanently
cement many temporary expansions
on the basis of coronavirus that's
democrats at least in the house
on the other hand as we talked about on
i think it was monday
republicans have more than 250 bills
in 43 different states to suppress
the vote to make it more difficult to
vote
so these are diametrically opposed
priorities
on these issues between democrats and
republicans democrats doing everything
they can
to increase participation in elections
republicans doing everything they can to
decrease participation now
you can take a cynical view and say well
both sides are doing what they think is
best for them for them
democrats believe more people voting is
good for democrats
republicans believe fewer people voting
is good for republicans
they are both probably correct the
difference is
one of them is actually in line with the
principles and values that this country
is based on which is not
disenfranchising people
giving people a voice not putting not
obstructing the ability of people to
participate in the democratic process
it's hard to argue
that the country is based on the values
that are exhibited by 250 republican
bills
in 43 states to suppress the vote so
yeah sure you can take the view that
it's quite simple
and it's democrats want more people to
vote so they win republicans want fewer
people to vote so they win
one of those perspectives happens to be
in line with the foundation of this
country now
as a very practical matter in the
immediate republicans
have a particularly pressing reason to
oppose
hr1 which is that they're winning the
house back in 2022
could depend on whether something like
hr1 passes or doesn't pass
and we'll talk more about that in the
future that's
hr1 let's now talk about coveted
stimulus
in this continuing almost never-ending
saga
of trying to get coveted relief passed
joe biden has negotiated not with
republicans
but with more moderate democrats to
further restrict who is eligible for a
stimulus check
what if you're wondering great
now that they've negotiated which
republicans are going to support the
bill as a result of the negotiation the
answer is i'm not aware of any
this is democrats negotiating with
democrats
to weaken coveted stimulus just to get
it passed
and either way it doesn't appear as
though republicans are going to support
this
now i know that there are people in my
audience
who will be mad for this critique
but come on guys 2000 now i'm gonna get
to the pragmatic piece so just let me
let me work through it
okay here's the just disgusting
frustrating part of all of this
two thousand dollars became 1400 and
when i critiqued that some people wrote
to me and said david
it was obvious from the beginning joe
biden meant we would add 1400 to the 600
to make it 2000. that's not a fair
critique
you're doing a bad critique david okay
then i say well joe biden said it would
pass right away
and it didn't pass right away it's march
and i critiqued that and some people
wrote to me and said david you know
you should have known that when a
president says right away
they don't mean right away they mean
months okay
and now to get the 1400
check the checks are going to phase out
more quickly as
income goes up so here's the changes
that were made
under the old plan passed by the house
you get fourteen hundred dollars if your
income is up to seventy five thousand
and it starts phasing down to zero once
your income is a hundred thousand
under the new plan it's just more
restrictive the 1400
starts phasing out and it goes to zero
at
80 grand instead of at 100 grand
so in short in the house version anyone
making over a hundred thousand gets zero
in the senate version that was
negotiated yesterday between
uh biden and senate republicans anyone
earning over eighty thousand dollars a
year
gets zero now do i think that this is a
really dumb negotiation
yes the phase out at one hundred
thousand dollars was fine
but the reality is with a 50 50 majority
in the senate 50 50 with kamala
as the deciding vote in ties democrats
can't afford to lose a single vote
so joe manchin now has power jeanne
shaheen a democrat from new hampshire
who also wanted to restrict the checks
she has power she wants to take the
money saved
by dropping the limit and send that
money to hospitals
okay does it still make sense to pass
this bill
it does in addition to the stimulus
checks the bill has
350 billion dollars for states 130
billion dollars for opening schools
160 billion dollars for vaccinations and
tax testing
an enhanced child tax credit rental
assistance food assistance so
it's important to pass this regardless
and we can't keep
delaying it but is this a really lame
negotiation where it's democrats
negotiating with democrats and either
way republicans won't support it of
course it is
at some point we have to recognize even
though they're democrats
they're very moderate some we would even
say are almost
uh sort of like centrist republicans
people like joe manchin
it's just the reality um and it's not
even that i think it's that important
that people earning 98
000 get a check like it's more the idea
that
we have zero republicans on board it's
an emergency to pass this
and democrats are negotiating with each
other over whether the cutoff should be
80 grand or 100 grand it's sort of like
what are we doing here type of moment
i get that if you make 98 000
you make 1400 bucks in like five or six
days of work this is less about that
it's the big picture of absurdity of how
it hasn't even nearly been only because
of republicans that this hasn't
passed and of course the 15 minimum wage
is just gone from the bill altogether
but we've already covered that and we
knew it now on the on the minimum wage
i'm getting some emails which i support
okay i'm getting emails from people
saying david
you know the senate parliamentarian who
decided you can't do the 15
minimum wage in this bill the the senate
parliamentarian can just be overruled
it's not you know people are acting like
oh it would be a massive step to
overrule the senate parliamentarian
okay yeah it would or it wouldn't but
the truth is if you overrule the senate
parliamentarian
and you include a 15 minimum wage in the
coveted relief bill
i just don't think it passes i don't
think joe manchin votes for the bill
and you can't afford to lose a single
vote in the senate right now given that
no republicans plan to vote for it so
i'm just as disgusted as you are by
what's going on don't don't mistake this
for me
not being disgusted in a practical
reality
you they're just not going to vote for
it if it's in the bill it's not going to
pass
even if you override the senate
parliamentarian and put it in the bill
it's not going to get passed now you
could make the argument and i know some
in my audience will
that it's worth it and it's worth it not
passing
to get those democratic senators on the
record saying they're against it they're
already on the record they've said it at
interviews they've they've put
statements out
so you're just slowing down getting
money to anybody
and uh but bottom line is
we've been talking about since november
4th
even with the two georgia senate seats
that democrats took from republicans
you still need to convince joe manchin
that wasn't an understatement that
wasn't just something i said for fun
it's joe manchin and it's gene shaheen
and over the next couple of years
it'll be one or two other democratic
senators as well the answer is we have
to flip more seats
saying primary joe manchin in west
virginia
if you run bernie in west virginia
against joe manchin and somehow
bernie wins the primary then a
republican wins that seat
the the answer isn't to to i mean listen
primary joe manchin if you want i'm not
saying don't
but the solution here is you need more
than a 50 50 majority
uh and then you know we get to the
question of is this the last and final
coveted stimulus our friend congressman
ro connor last week on the show
said he doesn't think it should be the
final stimulus i would love
to not need another coronavirus stimulus
that's going to be determined by how
quickly cases decline
how quickly vaccinations increase i'm
not seeing an
appetite for more stimulus after this
bill is done
at the congress level although some
individual members of the house and
senate do want more stimulus
this may actually be it and it would be
great if nothing else was needed
but that's just a it remains a question
mark
send me your thoughts about all of this
negotiation you can find me on twitter
deepakman the david pakman show at
davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist dot
com slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show is not funded by
big corporations or rich corporate
donors regardless of what you see posted
in the comments of my youtube channel
uh in all seriousness don't even look at
the comments it's pretty toxic
but in all seriousness you can support
the show by grabbing a membership
at joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code better21
to save hugely off of a membership
you'll get
the daily members only bonus show as
well as commercial free audio and video
feeds of the show
sign up at joinpackman.com uh this
morning i was browsing the david pakman
show
subreddit where nearly 30 000 of our
viewers and listeners are now subscribed
you can find the subreddit at
davidpakman.com
slash reddit that's r-e-d-d-i-t
very interesting post this morning
about how the actual effective tax rate
for the bottom eighty percent of people
is actually higher in texas than in
california
there's been a big movement lately uh
including in the context of covid people
wanting more
freedom and particularly with the recent
news that texas republican governor greg
abbott is ending all covet guidelines
ending mass mandates opening everything
wide open in texas
there's been this idea for a while and
it's been both bolstered by certain
um celebrities like joe rogan and elon
musk announcing they are abandoning
california and going to texas
there's this assumption that you just
pay a lot less in taxes if you go to
texas and
that is true for people who make a lot
of money
but the reality is that for a lot of
people
the state tax rate is actually higher in
texas
when you consider state and local taxes
and there's a really good post about
this
it's actually someone posted it to our
subreddit but it's a link to the joe
rogan subreddit
um and and it outlines this and i think
that uh it's
important to understand that in some
cases
when you go from a so-called high tax
state to a low tax state
you really are paying less in taxes in
many cases you're not there are states
with no state income tax where property
taxes and sales taxes for example are
significantly higher
we've talked before about how you can
also hide taxes
in other transaction fees there are
places where you might say oh the sales
tax is low
and there's a low or no income tax
but every fee associated with uh
driving a car insurance requirements on
different elements
there are lots of different ways in
which living in one state versus another
can be more expensive and
people who make decisions based solely
on state income tax
are often what's the word
they they receive a rude awakening when
they realize that hey i'm not paying a
state income tax anymore or not one
that's as high
but i'm paying all of these new and
different things very interesting
analysis i encourage you to look at it
in detail
another post and this this is sort of
like from the news of the obvious and
unsurprising
the creator of that cpac golden trump
statue
now admits that it was made in china um
i don't know how many of you even
followed this story but there was this
incredibly cult-like i mean really
disturbingly cult-like
golden trump statue
that was wheeled through cpac the
conservative political action conference
over the weekend which we covered and
aside from it all being really weird
because people were almost like
praying at the altar of this thing
extraordinarily cult-like trumpian
behavior people started asking where was
this thing made this would be really
expensive to make in the united states
and
i guess initially the guy who made it
said it was made in mexico
i don't even know if that's good or bad
but then we ultimately found out that it
was actually made in china
and i i don't even think we have to
comment a lot of the trump campaign gear
for years was made in china while trump
was publicly
saying china's crushing us on this
china's crushing us on that well
partially maybe they're crushing us
because you're giving them your own
business
we now found out that the trump golden
statue was made in china not surprising
but predictably hypocritical
join the discussion by joining the
subreddit
at davidpakman.com r-e-d-d-i-t
you know one of the things that we used
to cover on the show regularly
before gay marriage was legalized
nationally were
all sorts of wild claims from religious
right people
about all of the terrible things that
they thought gay people were doing and
this ranged from
gay people or indoctrinating children
into being gay
children are being convinced to be gay
by gay people
to all sorts of things i don't even want
to say because i don't want this video
to be demonetized
this type of thing died down a little
bit when gay marriage was
legalized nationally and the anti-gay
focus
shifted to so-called religious freedom
but things are now coming full circle
and once again these wacky right-wing
politicians are getting into the same
sort of stuff again and this might be
one of the most ridiculous ones i've
seen
this happened yesterday this is an
interview with
newly minted trumpian republican
congresswoman lauren bobert
whose big um issue has been she wants to
carry guns on the floor of the house of
representatives she went on something
called the war room
and or real america's voice i don't even
fully understand
what this is and she stated i hope
you're sitting down
she stated that the equality act
currently uh being worked on
in congress is really a bill for gay and
lesbian supremacy
and she believes that it is being this
is her word
it is also being carried out by transvex
hikes
transvex hikes yes that's her word not
mine
take a listen to this we can't say the
same for the so-called equality act
which we all know uh that that's just
the democrats uh using a play on words
there's nothing about
equality in that act if anything um it's
it's the um it's
it's supremacy of uh of gays and and
lesbians and
and uh trans vet sykes i mean like
that's what this is about is about
putting them
higher than anyone else it's not about
equality trans vex
hikes that that is really something else
this is what happens when you elect
people who
know nothing stand for nothing
and bring nothing to the table but they
supported trump and that's why you voted
for them this is the this is what
happens
and i've talked but this applies to
marjorie taylor green
this applies to madison cothorn people
who basically run
social media uh offices they don't
run policy offices they run social media
offices and of course this is
embarrassing
it's homophobic it's disgusting it's
pathetic it's all of the different
things that we've known these folk
folks to be for a long time but
i'll take this as an opportunity to talk
a little bit about the equality act it's
not about
trans vex hike supremacy and of course
the word is transgender i want to be
clear that it's not just that she's
mispronouncing the word
the word we use is transgender but one
of the most important things
that this bill would do is it would
amend the 1964
civil rights act to explicitly prevent
discrimination based on sexual
orientation
and gender identity i've spoken before
since
gay marriage was legalized nationally in
uh by the supreme court decision
there are still many states in which you
can discriminate against people
based on their real or perceived sexual
orientation that is not banned federally
at this point in time
this act would ban it and that's
extraordinarily important
the equality act would also expand
protections for protected classes
beyond just employment and housing it
would cover any federally funded program
it would include
public accommodations which means retail
stores stadiums and other venues yes
this does relate to the anti-gay cake
baker
it would impact that sort of situation
and the playbook for opponents of the
equality act
is very predictable and we're seeing it
there with lauren bobert
it's assassination of character it's i
guess also creating new words
like trans vex hikes but it's also
saying that the bill goes too far
it's saying the bill threatens
businesses
or people who might have legitimate
religious objections to serving lgbt
individuals in their businesses now the
bill does need 60 votes in the senate
it's unclear democrats can find 10
republicans to get this done
we know you know we talk about it's the
same conversation
maybe susan collins maybe lisa murkowski
mitt romney has already said he's not
going to vote in favor of this in the
senate
a rob portman is unclear whether he has
any interest in voting for this in the
senate so
it looks much like the same old story
we're going to observe and see
but trust me this is not about transvex
hike supremacy that's the last thing
that this is about
and we'll have more coverage of this
bill and covet relief
uh and hr one on our instagram page find
us at davidpakmanshow on instagram
follow me on instagram at david.pakman
as well
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing you get access to the world famous
bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free
audio and video feeds of the show
day in and day out you can sign up for
membership
very very quickly at joinpacman.com
that's
join p a k pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by
all means use the coupon code better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
welcome back to the david pakman show
today we're going to be speaking with
james fletcher who is the producer and
director of the documentary film
the accidental president i appear in
this film i've played the
trailer for my audience on on the live
stream
uh that that i've done recently and i i
appear very early in the trailer which i
really appreciate
uh james it's so it's so great to have
you on okay so
the accidental president um i think we
can sort of infer the idea that donald
trump
wanted to run for president not
necessarily to to be president talk to
us about the premise there
well i mean it's it's like the plot of a
ridiculous hollywood movie that got out
of control i mean i can test this was an
attention-seeking
exercise that went crazy and donald
trump was looking for a bit of attention
and suddenly by breaking all the rules
if you like of campaign
uh law he became the front-runner in the
republican field
and the thing ran away and we all know
what happened so
the the the title alludes to the fact
that this was
nothing more than a bit of fun he was
having and suddenly
it took on a whole life of its own in
the film
you interview all sorts of folks from
sort of more pragmatic
traditional republicans all the way to
what i guess i would
call more cultish true believers like
scott adams of dilbert fame
uh can you talk a little bit about what
were the trends you saw
in terms of their perspective on this
presidency of trump's
comparing the more traditional
republicans who have been involved in
the party for
for some time versus these kind of new
entrants
who who are really trump fans more than
they are anything else
well of course you know the trump
president once one title we we played
with for the film was was the hostile
takeover but i thought trump would have
liked that too much
but he in fact did the same to the
republican party and as you say
the republican establishment were
shocked and completely unprepared for
his arrival they didn't know how to deal
with it or
or confront him as a candidate and of
course they treated him
for the most part as a joke um which so
in finding our interviewees we wanted to
look at people from all
corners of the establishment we spoke to
matt schlapp
the chairman of cpac who i don't think
was a trumpista if one's really honest
about it right
um but then we went as you say to people
like scott adams
at the time wasn't really pro-trump as
he
is now um because we wanted to
illustrate that
inside the republican party there were
two very different
factions um you know people who believe
in the gop
and people who believe in trump do you
know
who so there's all these stories of even
up to election day trump still didn't
think he was going to win
and was shocked when when he won uh and
and in contrast to that there was the
republican primary process in 2016 which
started with 17 and as it started to get
whittled down
trump ended up sort of uh accruing
the support from all of these people
whose one two three percent support
ended up having to find a new place to
go
who figured out that trump could win
more quickly the people immediately
around trump or the republican
establishment that was watching this
that's a really good question i honestly
don't know the answer but what was
explained to me was
if you for example hated or you loved
ted cruz but you hated
uh i don't know um marco rubio you
thought well
i'll put them i'll put the the votes on
trump because he's gonna he's he's not
gonna do well anyway he'll probably drop
out i should that's sorry that's a
terrible example because they were some
of the last people standing right
um if you take um if you take uh rand
paul for example there's one percent
right i mean you would transfer your one
percent to trump because that was before
christmas and people thought
this was all a bit of fun but it would
be it would be over fairly soon
and so trump was blessed by this
mathematical advantage of having 16
opponents
and as these as these people fell out
one by one
um almost for a bit of entertainment if
i think a lot of people
are really honest with themselves they
put the money on trump because
he was such compelling viewing so
entertaining in a
field of republicans where the other 16
basically blurred into one um and i
think entertain the entertainment value
as trump is not to be underestimated
in any way that's interesting so some of
that trump support that shifted early
from the ones and twos as we were
calling them at the time
were people who were sort of thinking
eventually i will settle on whoever
is the nominee and it probably will be
somebody other than trump
that's right and this is a bit of
entertainment along the way
and we'll see where you know the cards
land and then we'll decide who we're
going to be serious about
uh but of course you know as is often
the case in politics you need to put
your stake in the ground earlier
earlier in the process rather than later
did you get any kind of sense of
when and how the republican
establishment when it became clear
that it was going to be trump as the
nominee not as the the eventual
president but as the nominee
if how did they or did they sort of race
into action to try to get control of the
candidacy
well that's right and matt schlapp talks
about this in the film i mean
that panic happened again too late uh
a lot of people treated trump as a bit
of
a sideshow and so they didn't tackle him
in the way he would have been tackled in
my opinion if he were
treated as a serious candidate from day
one um
and a lot of people thought the damage
he could do
to for example if i'm you know if i'm
against marco rubio it doesn't help hurt
me
to think he's going to insult marco
rubio or jed bush with the nicknames
and run them down so he's actually doing
me a favor and as long as he's in the in
the field
he's probably good for me but what a lot
of people over
overlooked was the fact that as molly
ball put it he would run through the
republican field like a buzz saw
and it was too late by the time people
in the republican establishment realized
this had happened and there was frankly
very little they could do about it
and certainly by the time he reached
1237
which people forget happened before the
convention so he goes
to the republican convention as the
presumed nominee
right and one of the things that we've
talked about in terms of that process
is that if donald trump had run as in
the democratic primary
he never would have stood a shot the are
fundamental
differences between the democratic
primary electorate and the republican
primary electorate which even if
accounting for this idea of
uh i wanted rand and he's out i'll say
trump but eventually i'll go with
whoever it is jeb even if you account
for that trump would have never gone
anywhere in the democratic primary did
any of the people you spoke to
in some way comment on or
understand that this was only possible
because of who
republican primary voters are i think
that's right and
you know it's also worth mentioning that
at the convention there was an attempt
to
destabilize the trump candidacy and paul
manafort got a lot of credit for
spotting those
threats and and seeing them off but yes
i mean fundamentally the difference
between the two parties was
magnified and made very clear uh by the
way trump was able to march
through that field uh un effectively
unchallenged
at this point is there any sort of
uh you can't argue with success type of
perspective
because of what donald trump was able to
do or does the fact that he was made
only the tenth one term president
and this is this is post filming of of
the the documentary but
it's sort of more of a now question um
does the fact that he was made a
one-term president in some way vindicate
the people who early on were not trump
people
it's really interesting thought but i
mean i would say
one of one of the covert killed trump i
mean i i i don't know where you stand on
that but i think
i agree he yeah i think without coving
he probably would have sailed through
re-election
um but you know nevertheless for four
years his business card said president
of the united states and he won and i
you know and as painful as that is for a
lot of people you know our film is
looking at how he won
and how basically a game show host
became the most powerful person on the
planet because it happened
and admittedly it was a perfect storm of
all kinds of luck bizarre circumstances
as you say the republican establishment
and their rules
but but he won and nearly won twice and
so i contest
there is a very solid basis on which to
launch the inquiry in this case
a documentary called the accidental
president what do you think is the
desire of the more traditional
republican party insiders that would be
the future of the republican party
because now there's this question with
people like madison cawthorne and lauren
beaubert and marjorie taylor greene
who really are only in congress because
they were on trump's side and
and they they were simpatico to trump we
don't know whether they will be
reelected or not in 2022 and there's a
real question as to whether
the republican party will remain a
trumpian party or go back to what it was
before
the the more traditional insider types
that you interviewed in the film what do
you think they want now
well i think it's i think 2022 will be
really interesting if
if republicans come storming back and
trump in some way
as this de facto leader of the
opposition i know that's not an office
obviously in american politics
but he's not put himself there if they
do very well in 2022
and his people and he can take the
credit for it would
forget whatever credibility then i think
trump stays and
it'll be very diffic difficult to
dismiss him
however if it's a wipeout in 2022 i
think
people in the republican establishment
will say trump is now a massive
liability and we've got to find a way of
getting rid of him
yeah i wonder if that you know at the
cpac speech there was the rumor trump
might announce for 2024
and then of course he didn't but he did
announce you know you can donate money
on his website and he's going to be
supporting candidates in 2022.
it almost seems like a trial balloon
where if he can continue to sort of play
king maker and wield influence
successfully in 2022
maybe it makes his 24 run more likely
and if it doesn't work then he can
not necessarily gracefully exit but at
least exit that's right and of course
david
you know if he were to run in 2024 and
won for us he put it a third time
uh you know i'm sure you'd have no
contest at that point yeah um
but yeah i think i i do think 2022 will
be
the moment at which the republican party
will either decide
we've got to hang on to him even if we
can't stand the thought because
he does win for us and this is all you
know
this is not my opinion uh but uh
if if it's a wipeout then i think i
don't i mean the problem is
there isn't an obvious candidate which
you would think by now there might be
um so 2022 i think is going to be a
pivotal moment for the republican
establishment
how much does all of this number one
depend on and will be guided by
what's going on in other parts of the
world because at the time of trump we
also had the rise of some of these
nationalist right-wing parties in
different parts of europe
uh the boris johnsonization uh in
in england and all of these different
things and that that also may change
over the next two to four years does it
is trump big enough now that it it
doesn't matter anymore or is there still
some kind of global picture here that
will dictate
i don't know and correct me if you
disagree but i'm not sure that what's
happening outside of america
particularly informs what happens inside
america i mean
the brexit vote for me was an indication
that this that trump could happen right
but i don't think it
it's it's possible to say that trump
happened because of brexit or that it
paved
the way i think the conditions in
america were amenable to trump win
um which wasn't as obvious at the time
as it was in retrospect
um so i'm not sure global politics will
have much bearing
yeah i'm not inclined to uh at least not
to disagree strongly
in terms of the production of the film
and we're talking with james fletcher
about the documentary the accidental
president
you produced it over quite a period of
time
what is the how do you even manage
logistically
you have all of these interviews you
have the big picture story you want to
tell
i i'm trying to figure out what how are
you organized day to day
to end up putting the story you want to
tell together from all the footage that
you
have what happened was we finished our
last interview with kellyanne conway the
very day trump announced lockdown
in the united states so that was i think
early march
of last year yeah and we started editing
literally a week before lockdown um i
just appointed the editor
and so i never spent any time in the
same room as him
um which is extraordinary and unheard of
when you're working on any film
and the same is true of everyone else in
post-production the composer was in los
angeles
the sound design was done in london the
color uh was of the picture was done in
texas by a guy from new york who was in
lockdown with his wife's family
so it was a real challenge um
and all the uh you know meetings that
you would normally have in person and
trial and error and creative ideas
weren't possible in the normal way
but we we got there and but
we i think what you're asking is we we'd
locked the film from june 15 until
election day of 2016 so in a way it
didn't really matter
the the only thing i was personally
disappointed was that we had to release
the film later than i'd like to but it's
a balanced piece
anyway i don't think it would have made
any difference to the outcome of the
election had we released it
for example in september as you know
people encouraged
encouraged us to um i think if i wanted
to affect the
election i'd have had to basically do a
hit job on trump and that's not what
this film is
when you're sitting there and you're
you're putting it together and as people
will see
when they watch it that there will be
you know i'll say something and then
it'll cut to
somebody else and then a third person
are you working off of
transcripts to say we want this line and
then this line or
are you going from memory from the
interviews which seems like it would be
so difficult to do
um it was a bit of both i mean i i did
all the transcripts myself so
in my head i had all the the lines i
liked then i went through
the transcripts with literally pen and
paper and i put lines under
for example all the things i wanted to
to put in the film that you said
then of course you're into the fact that
we're it's just under 120 minutes 110
minute film
and so sadly when you've got 20 almost
one hour interviews a lot of things
don't make it into the final cut which
is really frustrating
and then you know people have asked us
is should this have been a ten part
you know limited series i'm not sure
people would have the stomach for that
i'm not sure i would have had the
stomach to make it and watch
as much trump as they did um but
it we didn't have a plan and everyone
approaches documentary making a
different way but
i think between me and
noah the editor it was really the two of
us who who did
this whole thing and obviously massive
credit to him
um yeah we we just followed our nose we
were we probably
would not get an a in film school for
the way we did it
but i just felt it had to feel very
natural and keep moving and so
we were brutal in edit if someone was
waffling or going on
too long bang the the sentence was cut
in half
right that's how most of my footage
ended up being cut in fact
because there was of the waffling no
possible no
uh no it's it's a it's an excellent
documentary we're talking with james
fletcher the
producer and director of the accidental
president and
where are the easiest places for people
to find the film
so it's on apple tv in 72 countries
we've
translated the subtitles into less than
american spanish um it's also on amazon
and uh google play so the whole android
platform is covered as well
and youtube james thank you so much uh
for talking to us about it
thank you very much david the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us
on tv or even listen on the radio
patreon.com
slash david pakman show
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
people are finally starting to wake up
to something crucial
something i've been talking about for
years when republicans wage a war
against so-called cancel culture when
the right
decries businesses making decisions
about what's best for them because of
backlash from the public what they are
criticizing what they are fighting
against
is the very free market that they have
been defending almost to the death i
mean it's almost a religion
for these people the free market and
they've been doing it
really since the reaganization of
republican politics
in the 1980s this um a
prayer at the altar of free market
capitalism
and this exposes a deeper truth
about the american right wing not only
are they short on policy as we've talked
about
many times and not only do they simply
play on values even the values they play
on
are only relevant up to the point at
which it becomes inconvenient
what i mean by that is they talk about
the power
and the efficiency of markets to guide
economies and cultures and countries
they say markets are much smarter than
government officials or politicians
but then as we saw this week when dr
seuss's publisher decides
here's six books out of a whole bunch
here's six books
that we're going to stop publishing
because some of the content doesn't
really fit into
uh what are considered acceptable uh
sort of social norms and
portrayals of minorities right now
that's a
free market decision made by a
for-profit company
because they looked at public opinion
and they said
let's make the decision that's best for
our bottom line and republicans
instantly throw their supposed values
out the window
and spend three days and probably it'll
be more
talking about the travesty of dr
seuss's so-called cancellation so not
only do they abandon
their supposed free market principles as
soon as they don't like the outcome
dictated by the market they also
weaponize it
into the very outraged porn that allows
them
to make money by covering this stuff on
tv
it's not new that they abandoned their
values when it's inconvenient this is
just the latest way
think back when democrats are in the
white house
all they talk about is debt and deficit
and the importance of balancing the
budget
george w bush comes into office among
other things give tax cuts to the rich
and goes to war a really expensive war
with the wrong country
and in so doing explodes the deficit
and they say nothing but then donald
trump comes into office
and then cuts taxes for the rich blows
up the deficit again
and they say nothing at all and yet not
only do they abandon their values when
it's not
convenient they want to inject
government into it
when a market guides a decision that
they don't like
and look at the trajectory on this dr
seuss thing
we are for free markets and keeping
government out
this means you would imagine businesses
do what they want as long as it's not
illegal and the government stays out of
it
dr seuss enterprises which made more
than 30 million dollars last year
decides here's six books we will not
continue to publish
they're not canceling dr seuss they're
not burning
books they're saying here's six books we
will allow to go out of print but if you
want to buy a used copy you can go ahead
and all of a sudden the sovereignty of
business to do what it wants to do
goes out the window but not only that
republicans including people like jim
jordan the congressman demand
congressional hearings on cancel culture
why is any of this the business of the
federal government
where is rand paul as a principled
libertarian
to say there is nothing for the federal
government to do related to this
we should have no role here whatsoever
hearings
no way in hell these are private
businesses making decisions however
they want to make them they're not
breaking any law
so quite simply the government should
have no involvement whatsoever
the market as they like to say should be
allowed
to work its magic if this decision by
seuss enterprises
is wrong then the market will take care
of it period
if more people are mad about this
decision than the number that like it
and they want to exercise their ability
to
participate in free market capitalism
they can say well i'm not going to buy
any dr
seuss books anymore i'll go buy whatever
i don't even know
and then the market will take care of it
this is their view
which they now are abandoning but the
truth is
that this has nothing to do with their
stated principles
what they mean by the free market is a
market that pushes society
and culture and institutions in the way
they want it to be pushed they don't
like the way that the market forces are
leaning right now
in the direction of sensitivity to
racial and ethnic issues they don't like
it
and that's fundamentally what this is
all about and this makes you know
i've said before this movement that only
wants to talk about
principles principles are a great place
to start
but when you only talk about principles
you enter what's called the
philosophical black hole
and the really difficult work is
figuring out real world situations this
is
so so one part of the principles
movement
that's bogus is that they very quickly
abandon their stated principles when the
outcome isn't what they want
but this is the other aspect of it that
when you only talk about principles
you end up with situations like this
they don't like it
that's what this is all about and then
this is also extraordinarily
profitable for many and that's what i
want to talk about next
so let's continue our discussion of the
fake cancel culture
war and the entire apparatus
that's been built around things like dr
seuss and mr potato head
in the midst of covered economic crisis
inequality lack of access to health care
falling humiliatingly and woefully
behind on climate on and on
i could give you the full list you know
the list dr seuss and mr potato head
are what we are hearing about in
right-wing media
this is something that lachlan marquette
marky i'm not sure i was pronounced
wrote about in axios this morning and
that's a really important aspect of this
the new grift is outrage profiteering
now in a sense outrage profiteering has
been around forever
the idea of if it bleeds it leads is
sort of a nod to outrage
profiteering we know that salacious and
controversial
stories in general generate better
ratings than stories about waterfalls
and gingersnaps
i don't pretend this doesn't apply to
the david pakman show if my show was all
about you know random good news
a charity built 10 toilets in some
country this week
we'd be out of business by now like i
completely recognize that what makes
many shows compelling
is you point to problems you point to
injustices you propose
solutions but lachlan markey
in axios outlines something that has
really grown lately
which is the grift of profiting off of
fake scandals and fabricated outrage
where there should really be no outrage
now marky writes about it in axios more
in the context of political fundraising
and campaigning
this is something i've talked about for
a long time if the country
is more and more in favor of gay
marriage being legal
of abortion being legal then at any
other point in history and it is the
country is as
left as it's ever been on those issues
why do right-wing politicians
keep talking about those issues well the
reason is that those are issues
where if you are opposed to gay marriage
if you're opposed to abortion
you are often viscerally and emotionally
opposed and you are likely to donate
lots of money
to a candidate that shares your view on
those issues so even though the country
keeps moving further and further left
these remain great fundraising issues
for republicans
they profit from generating outrage
often fake
around things like you know democrats
want to abort your kids even when
they're three years old that type of
thing
but not only do republicans line their
pockets with this outrage porn and
profiteering
right-wing media does it as well look at
fox news over the last 72 hours
dozens of stories i'm not exaggerating
dozens of segments about dr seuss
and that's because the outrage generated
by the fake
headlines about dr seuss being canceled
and these being the new book burnings
those headlines generate way more
outrage
and thus interest and twitter shares and
facebook views of fox news clips
than a story about democrats past hr1
which by the way was our lead story
today on the show
and likewise there are now so many
so-called independent right-wing
channels that also
profit from fake scandals that they are
similarly grifting around this outrage
profiteering now i don't i don't want to
start naming names
i don't even want to give them publicity
many in my audience will know
the grift fake outrage channels that i'm
talking about
but this is the new grift and we
shouldn't
expect it to go away for as long as it's
profitable
now should our goal be to make it less
profitable well i
you know what if if we fix the problems
we have in this country
the outrage grifting will become less
profitable and what i mean by that is
when we look at how fake stories spread
they spread because they are weaponized
and targeted to
um uninformed people who don't know any
better and lack media literacy skills
with which they would say
it would be humiliating for me to share
this many people i went to high school
with don't seem to have this ability you
should see what i'm seeing on my
facebook page
um but people if they were more educated
and better equipped with media literacy
skills
they would never share lots of the stuff
that catches fire on social media
because people would say this is
obviously fake i'm not going to share it
so i don't know that the goal the
primary goal is not
let's make outrage profiteering less
profitable
the goal should be let's fix education
let's teach epistemology media literacy
and give people tools which will
naturally
make this sort of outrage profiteering
less profitable
it won't be unprofitable it it will be
profitable to some degree
because of the tendency toward to to to
where people gravitate to
salacious and explosive stories even if
they're fake but we could definitely
take the win
wind out of it uh by uh better ed with
better education
uh teaching media literacy and equipping
people with the tools that they need
to identify that this is not something i
want to be sharing we have a voicemail
number that number is 219
to david p every few months
the san antonio troll comes out of the
woodwork
and this guy has been calling in for
years at this point
and what i love about this caller is
almost
every time he calls in he criticizes me
for something i haven't even talked
about and he's doing that again today
and what's really funny is
some of what he mentions i haven't
talked about
some of what he mentions i haven't even
heard about i don't know what he's
talking about here listen to this
pac-man i think i've solved it i have
solved
why why you don lemon
uh joy behar bill maher
[Music]
vosh all the you know the same topic you
all have the same kind of
exact politics okay i figured out why
it's one point
by the way bill maher and vosh do not
have the same politics okay let's
continue who's
why for one none of y'all are talking
about why the 15
minimum wage is getting the they're
kicking the can to 2025.
none of y'all spoke about that but
instead we're worried about who's
starring in the next disney plus film
i i've never i don't i didn't even know
there was a controversy about the next
disney plus film
and that's superman gonna be black is
this i didn't even hear about
anything about superman being black
these are stories i haven't even heard
of nevermind talked about why is he
calling me
he should be calling people who talked
about it nike colin kaepernick and nike
shoes
i figured out why we're more worried
about that than actual workers getting a
fair wage
because you're rich are you done with
the all around me i got money
who cares if workers get more wages but
disney that's what y'all like disney
posted netflix so it's important
that they have disney plus i i don't
know what he's talking about you know
non-white actors and stuff like
i get it but man dude we some of us
really need money man where's that
covered relief your boy biden profits
i i and it's funny he he's acting like
i'm talking about disney plus and not
coveted relief
who who on the left uh has been more
critical
of the delay on this than i have i mean
i'm lots of people
are being critical but we we've been
following the delays on kovatov
from day one we've been covering the the
watering down of covered relief from day
one i think this guy's got the wrong
show
nowhere in sight they keep pushing it
delaying it this and maddie i'm with you
at all of 2020 funny
2025 and it's a thousand dollars now and
i see it's the same thing and it's
you you guys keep making excuses but
instead on your
i've made no excuses channel the most
important thing in the world
is disney plus netflix yeah so that's
the san antonio troll
and you know i wish he he does things a
lot of people don't do
he's audible in the voicemails a lot of
people call calling you can't hear what
they're saying
he gets right to the point a lot of
people call in they go three minutes and
before they even get to the point the
voicemail system
the san antonio troll could be a good
caller but
he's criticizing me for things that i've
never even talked about and sometimes
that i don't even know about it's sad
it's a sad state of affairs we've got a
great bonus show for you today mike
pence finally breaks his silence
and he's criticizing the 2020 election
we will talk about why some u.s catholic
bishops are discouraging
parishioners from getting the johnson
and johnson vaccine
we will also talk about parlor suing
amazon
again and what's going on with that all
of those stories
and more on today's bonus show
get instant access by signing up at
joinpakman.com
the coupon code remains available the
coupon code is
better21 all one word could be lowercase
you could spell it all caps you could
alternate it's not case
sensitive but it is all one word better
21
at joinpackman.com i'll see you on
today's bonus show
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman